task queues allows you to take the job
offline so you can create a task queue
and then add a hundred tasks that each
has the job to send a hundred emails
tasks can be created from any user
activity and be put on this queue and as
we will see later these tasks are not
executed in the user requests thread so
you can immediately return a response to
the user but one question remains then
how will these mails % that actually
depends on the type of queue you use but
before we go into that it's time for you
to answer a question so the question is
which is best to use the HTTP request
thread or task queues when you want to
generate a report or register a new user
checking out the shopping cart or do
photo face recognition